die zahlen explodieren und zwar in
kürzester zeit die betten sinnvoll die
lage wird täglich schlechter die zahl
der infektion erhöht sich wenn es keine
bundeseinheitliche regelung gibt
dann wird land unter sein vor
weihnachten
[Musik]
ja darüber wollen wir natürlich sprechen
und zwar mit dem spd gesundheitsexperten
karl lauterbach schönthaler lauterbach
schöne sie zeit für uns haben die erste
frage ist natürlich was muss dieser
gipfel jetzt beschließen welche
maßnahmen kommen auf uns zu
zunächst einmal der gipfel morgen nach
ist gespräch morgen ist wird sich ja in
erster linie mit dem urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes beschäftigen
und dann wird auch der krisenstab uhr
vorgestellt werden ob dann weitergehen
schlüsse aus so gefasst werden das steht
derzeit noch dahin wichtig ist dass wir
uns jetzt gut überlegen was zu tun ist
und also da machst du da hat ja recht
das auch so
maßnahmen notwendig sind aber es ist
nicht so wie es ein bisschen jetzt sage
ich dass wenn nicht funktionieren würde
selbst in bayern verbessert sich die
lage jetzt langsam und die maßnahmen die
ergriffen worden sind wirken sie müssten
aber noch einmal nachgeschärft werden
also um das noch mal kurz
zurechtzurücken da gibt es morgen einen
kleinen corona gipfel sozusagen der
telefonschalte und sie rechnen gar nicht
damit beschlüssen richtig
es kommt darauf an was man unter
beschlüssen versteht jetzt ist erst
einmal das umzusetzen was schon gehe und
ob darüber hinaus gehende schlüssel
kommen das wird sich zeigen also dass
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt steht das noch
nicht fest was auf jeden fall also
gemacht werden muss wir müssen den
krisenstab einsetzen und wir müssen über
hass man das
verfassungsgerichts urteil sprechen und
bei anderer maßnahmen dann wird auf
jeden fall auch gesprochen werden aber
auch sie schon gefasst werden das steht
das ist noch unklar wird er da
tatsächlich auch über einen
bundeseinheitlichen lockdown gesprochen
sowie markus söder das gefordert hat
denn ich glaube dass das in einigen
anderen bundesländern zum beispiel im
norden wo die insolvenzen relativ
niedrig sind nicht so gut ankommt ein
bundeseinheitlicher lockern würde ja
bedeuten dass wir auch soziale begrenzte
zeit dass die geschäfte schließen und
die gastronomie schließen dass wir im
prinzip alles runter fahndet wegen zwei
wochen um die fallzahlen drastisch zu
senken das wird sicherlich morgen nicht
geschlossen werden weil die
modellierungen die jetzt das so
vorgenommen worden sind die wir am
wochenende ausgewertet haben zeigen dass
das nicht passt gerecht ist was ich
immer stärker zeit wir haben große
probleme in den schulen
dort muss die masken sich ganz dringend
streng umgesetzt werden für alle schüler
und zwar überall wir brauchen dort aus
routinemäßiges testen wir brauchen
einschränkungen für ungeimpfte da kann
man sich sogar vorstellen dass die
ungeimpften auf eine kontaktperson
außerhalb des eigenen aus reduziert
werden und wir brauchen insbesondere
eine einschränkung war denen auch so
falls hat ähnliche dienstleistungen also
ist besonders clubs bars diskotheken die
müssen aus meiner sicht bezahlt man
geschlossen werden war die modelle
zeigen ganz klar dass an diesem
wochende vergnügungen leider ein großer
teil der infektionen geschieht und da
kommen wir mit 2g und zwei grundlos
nicht den also kneipen locker und
sozusagen zu nennen wir das sind ja
keine knallten in erster linie sondern
es sind also größere rolle quasi
diskotheken clubs bars dann muss das man
sich also eine schließung verhängt
werden dass meine persönliche wagen auf
der grundlage der sichtung aller daten
wir haben was am wochenende noch einmal
die unterschiedlichen modelle
ausgewertet wir haben am wochenende
haben wir in diesen bereichen wirklich
sehr viele kontakte und ansteckungen das
können wir uns nicht länger leisten die
frage zielt ja gerade auch nochmal auf
markus söder der sozusagen ganz
deutschland zwingt das so zu machen wie
es in bayern laufen toll sie sind
bestimmt gleich zurück und wieder zu
sehen lauterbach ich hoffe sie können
meine fragen auch wenn wir schrauben
noch mal ganz kurz an der verbindung
plötzlich war das bild weg zur
lauterbach guter dinge dass wir das noch
mal gebastelt bekommen also wir reden ja
hier über einen bundeseinheitlichen
locker und also ist das überhaupt
sinnvoll alles so zu machen wie die
bayern das machen wollen wohin die werte
ganz besonders hoch sind markus söder
treibt an will das eben
bundeseinheitlich machen also ganz genau
so in schleswig-holstein wohl noch kaum
corona fälle auf der intensivstation
liegen wie in bayern wo eben die
intensivstation voll sind mit corona
patienten ruf doch mal ganz kurz karl
lauterbach können sie uns hören wenn sie
uns irgendwann will ich wieder okay
wunderbar her scheint die frage zielt
noch mal sozusagen auf den so der plan
ist das sinnvoll dass in
schleswig-holstein aktuell genauso zu
machen wie in bayern in münchen ich
glaube dass das nicht sinnvoll ist weil
also wir natürlich bei denen also zweig
und zwei gibt es regeln immer daran
denken müssen was ist angemessen
trotzdem bin ich der meinung dass es
bundesweit sinnvoll ist tatsächlich
clubs bars und diskotheken zu machen
weil dort ist das infektionsgeschehen so
ausgeprägt dass dort in wesentlichen
bundesweit kein spielraum ist und auch
also die maske pflicht bei den schüler-
und die tägliche tests und bei den
schülern das scheint mir ebenfalls eine
unbedingt notwendige maßnahmen zu sagen
das könnte man bundeseinheitlich machen
ausmalen dass ich genauso wie die also
kontakt beschränkungen der ungeimpften
aber viele andere bereiche
beispielsweise ihnen also beim einkauf
oder in der gastronomie
kommt auf die inzidenz an und man dann
mit 2g oder mit 2g plus arbeitet herr
lauterbach nun herrschte sehr viel
aufregung um die neue virusvariante
omikron gibt's da inzwischen neue
erkenntnisse wie gefährlich ist die
tatsächlich wie sehr unterscheidet sie
sich von den bisherigen varianten
na ja keine neuen erkenntnisse also ich
kenne so ziemlich alle studien dazu wie
viele kollegen habe ich der einzige der
dafür interessiert ich habe im moment
jeder und was klar ist dass man nicht
sagen kann diese variante ist weniger
gefährlich als die delta variante das
wissen wir zum jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht
diejenigen die sich infiziert haben die
waren oft jünger und die war vorher
krank somit also vor infiziert von daher
ist das eine situation
die also sehr schwer einzuschätzen ist
und
jetzt reißt herr lauterbach noch mal ab
aber wir schrauben noch einmal dran denn
12 fragen etwa da noch es wird doch so
heiß diskutiert nicht nur über die neue
virusvariante sondern vor allen dingen
wird der mann jetzt gesundheitsminister
oder nicht die spd hat sich immer noch
nicht entschieden mit was ein bisschen
schwierig ist meiner meinung nach dass
wir irgendwie in so einem schwebezustand
jetzt hier dahinplätschern wo es doch
eigentlich wahnsinnig wichtig wäre jetzt
jemanden an der spitze zu haben herr
lauterbach und es geht eben sehr viele
menschen die sich auch wünschen dass sie
gesundheitsminister werden warum machen
sie es nicht einfach ich bin erst mal um
entschuldigung dass hier mehrfach das
bild zusammengebrochen ist war die
technischen probleme dazwischen gekommen
sind bitte um verständnis dass so etwas
kann hier nicht nur personen gehen erst
über dieses ministerium gut besetzt wir
haben gute leute da bin ich also
sicher dass wir das gut hinbekommen
werden von daher ganz wichtig ist also
mich würde es freuen wenn wir diese
welle schnell brechen mit so wenig wie
möglich aber wurde dabei auch noch in
den staat zukommen wenn hinter uns nicht
entscheiden nicht die person ein haken
darf natürlich geht es auch um eine
person es braucht doch jemanden der
jetzt das zepter in die hand nimmt und
wenn wir einen jetzigen
gesundheitsminister haben der sagten ich
bin eigentlich raus mich geht das alles
nicht mehr an und das ist noch nicht mal
ein neuer bestimmt wie will man dann
durch die krise kommen das leuchtet mir
nicht so ganz ein wir werden in wenigen
tagen die personalien alle geklärt haben
von da ist dann klar jetzt da bis dahin
arbeiten wir eng zusammen ist da wohl
nicht der eindruck entstehen dass wenn
es jetzt ein vakuum gebe ich bin zum
beispiel im regelmäßigen kontakt noch so
mit jens spahn und bin da nur einer und
noch mit dem robert koch institut mit
vielen wissenschaftlern auch mit oder
schadet er selbst äußert oder sicher
auch damit die arbeit findet statt die
arbeit neu es ist nicht so dass wir dem
stillstand er selbst sieht das aber
anders hier entspannen der aktuelle der
noch gesundheitsminister der sagt das
wäre schon besser wenn man jetzt ein
übergang machen könnte wenn man den
kollegen oder die kollegen der danach
folgt die danach folgt schon mal
ordentlich einarbeiten könnte das fällt
leider flacht ist schon mal kein guter
start an
naja jetzt spannend also sollte dann
ehrlicher war es auch erwähnen wir sind
ja einen austausch ich bin für ihn immer
erreichbar wir tauschen zum beispiel
über die impfmöglichkeiten aus ich bin
ja nur einer von vielen dass wir sind da
ansprechbar wie auch die anderen
gesundheitspolitiker und es wird ja im
hintergrund auch intensiv zusammen
gearbeitet
man muss man ein bisschen vorsichtig
sein dass das ganze nicht auch so einen
parteipolitischen zungenschlag bekommt
danke herr lauterbach wir haben noch
zeit für eine ein wort an wort glauben
sie es denn punkt jetzt dass sie es
werden ja oder nein ich spekuliere
darüber nicht habe ich nicht getan durch
weiß er nicht aber ich danke ihnen also
für die möglichkeit dass nutzer
austauschen konnten wir danken herrn auf
und die liebe der csu schreibt ja
mittlerweile zu ihnen rüber die wünschen
sich ja mittlerweile karl lauterbach als
gesundheitsminister das ist auch eine
spektakuläre nachricht dieses wochenende
für das gespräch